I was thinking okay I am dying 400
pounds how people gonna Carry Me what
this Dua uh this thing make me make me
like uh almost cry even with the goats
yeah the goats is different level and I
start remembering if I go to the sajdah
and Imam gonna make long Dua in the
sajdah I can breathe what if somebody
came outside and touch my wife do some
how overweighted Imam will talk about
that to the public you had to actually
get a car based on your weight now
absolutely now I'm saying why did you
lie to me I wasn't just a big I was fat
ass I want you guys to go ahead and
watch this video and you can look at
this brother who was almost 400 pounds
he started with a Dua took some action
we want to know what was the Dua what
was the action to get him to where he's
at here with us today and he's sharing
his story so you can also inshallah
benefit make that change for the better
lose some of that weight like he did
we'll see you here in a second
if you go to the gym and you work out
and you come back and you look in the
mirror you will see
and if you go to the gym the next day
and you come back and you look in the
mirror you will see
nothing right so clearly there's no
results can't be measured it must not be
effective so we quit
if you believe there's something there
you commit yourself to an act of service
you commit yourself to the regime the
exercise you can screw it up you can eat
chocolate cake one day you can skip a
skip a day or two you know it allows for
that but if you stick with it
consistently I'm not exactly sure what
day but I know you'll start getting into
shape I know it
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
but you're in the neighboring City yeah
we are like a 300 kilometers around 200
miles from the Dagestan it calls nalchik
we have a very famous mount it it's
highest in the Europe it goes Albus so I
am a real mountain guy yeah
real mountain guy huh yeah we have a we
have a highest peak in the Europe it
calls Elvis we need to do this for the
future of our children the future of our
great country the future of mankind this
is your brother and I've got a very
important message alhamdulillah our
brother Eddie is setting up the dean
Center not just the dean show but the
dean Center a full dawa Academy a Masjid
a dawa Center in America the first of
its type the a groundbreaking project
and I want everybody as I'm supporting
it I want everybody to support it so we
can take the dawa to the next level we
need the dean Center please support it
foreign
and this video is showing you before and
after but that really doesn't look like
you you're almost like 400 pounds oh
yeah it was it was my journey to America
so when I came to America I was around
230 250 pounds and then my journey
started with the tracks semi trucks I
used to drive so what you gonna do on
the road you're gonna just a snake you
know you have like all of the like chips
and stuff and cokes all unhealthy stuff
so what you gonna do no exercises no
like healthy food nothing like that
nothing with clothes so clothes so
you're gonna have to gain weight in this
case there is no way not to gain so it
was obviously bad bad habits you know
bad food habits but before you came to
America you were eating better food at
that point at that point uh I used to do
Judo back in the middle school and the
high school actually even from the high
uh like a great first I started going to
uh practicing the Judo so I was okay
then after grade nine I start like
gaining little by little but I was like
just a few extra pounds you know I
wasn't like a big you know nothing like
that I wasn't the okay shape so when I
came to uh us I started gaining weight
because now I'm realizing after I start
eating clean and stuff like that I start
checking the sugar and stuff I see it's
a lot of hidden sugar in anything you
eat like starting with the gum even
ketchup even ketchup has a lot of sugar
so what you gonna do you have to you're
gonna gain the weight so but when you
were living in back home now the food
would you say it was closer towards more
being real food healthier food compared
to here sure absolutely we used to grow
everything in our backyard this is this
is the environment how I grew up and you
know what's the interesting part I went
to school in the city from the my
Village I used to go to the city and uh
what happened
when they asked me about Hobby what is
your hobby I'm like What's the Hobbies
because if I have a free time I'm
working on the yard on the backyard we
are planting we are like harvesting
harvesting so this is all about you know
this was our hobby so all the potatoes
like a tomato anything any fruits we
used to grow ourselves it was like a
organic like we had our animals like
chickens like a Lambs everything we used
to do everything ours so cheese like
everything hours raw milk you know I
even remember my grandma
my grandma after she milked the cow she
she pulled me I had my special cup she
pulled for me like a fresh milk right
under the cow and I was drinking every
night so this was that this was the
lifestyle that I had because people look
at you now they can't recognize you and
they're like people think that's almost
like impossible it's very difficult it's
gonna be a lot of work but it all
started it off with you making a Dua you
talk about making a dog it started from
there and then you put action behind
that Dua can we start about start with
that
Brothers uh brother Eddie I want to tell
you something this Dua this thing make
me make me like uh almost uh cry when I
when I realize it uh
Ramadan last Ramadan before this one
it was 20 20.
I was on the Ithaca for the 10 10 days
last 10 days in the Masjid and I was
making few to us a lot of Duos but I I
put a lot of a lot of time on those
three I had the issue with my wife's
Visa so bringing her here so it was
around like four years I couldn't make
it uh to us I was making for that I was
making for my uh first child I didn't
have it for that same amount of time
about four years and for sure I was
making for my uh weight loss
and that time I was on keto I was trying
keto and it was okay losing gaining
losing gaining I make that three to us
for past or for last 10 days and
subhanallah right after the Ramadan
after one month I came back home we go
to the doctor we checked they checked
her they said she's like uh one week or
something uh pregnant so what's what's
going on I make a Dua as soon as I get
home Allah give it so I make a Dua I
make it something what was the Duos
people I just just as you can yeah well
Allah give me give me my give me the
child so that's the first one for your
child yeah if you want a child for my
wife to bring it here yeah and for my
weight loss so what happened and then
you're asking a lot to help you to lose
this weight absolutely but you're not
just sitting on the couch no no no you
can't you can't sit in the couch you
have to tight your you have to tie your
camel then make it awako so behind
behind every Dua you should have some
action you have to step towards Allah
Allah will step it
to you so alhamdulillah I make that Dua
and then I started little by little
when I we went to the doctor she said
she's already so after like three three
weeks of being home uh when I came home
after three weeks we checked she's
pregnant like that two weeks or
something so look at this connection
right there like just came home
alhamdulillah Allah answered so second
effort what I do I go to the doctor to
check myself for the weight loss yeah I
went there I checked I take the guidance
from the doctor I start
following the steps now I start losing
the weight what were the steps that the
doctor told you just just the regular
like like you're gonna hear from
everywhere just uh first of all you have
to check everything so from the top to
the bottom because I used to try like
all uh possible diets so what I did they
checked me up from the top to the bottom
they seem efficiency the efficiency of
the old vitamins and everything in my
body so blood work blood work absolutely
this is very important because we know
like everybody's saying take fish oil
take this oil take this this what if you
don't need it so you have to go see what
your body needs yeah watch you exactly
in it so this is what first step Second
Step he gave me the diet diet plan so I
start from that and the diet plan wasn't
something like a it was just a
nutritionist or who was who gave you
this diet it was Tim it was it was team
nutritionist doctors it was one team
yeah who helping with the weight loss
yeah so specific team specifically it
helps with weight loss yes absolutely
they even they even had like a little
book for me so step by step for 30 days
to follow it up so but what's the
important uh thing uh Eddie I want to
say you cannot you cannot keep in your
mind that thing as a diet you have to
change your mind you have to change your
lifestyle towards healthy lifestyle so
so it's not gonna be like okay three
months I'm gonna lose 20 pounds 30
pounds that's it I'm gonna go back eat
this junk it's not gonna work like that
you have to change your mind so this is
all about and then all our problems or
all our things diseases it starts from
here
if you're giving signal from the from
here to your body your body gonna obey
but when you have messed up mindset this
is this is the this is the root so this
is what I think you know now I'm gonna
have a baby so I have to move around I
have to carry her I have to help and
stuff you know I definitely have to have
action so that that was huge motivation
for me absolutely also uh
pictures that I see didn't satisfy me
because I wasn't like that big you know
almost 400 pounds it was like I'm huge
you know so I barely moved you know I
can't find the clothes in the stores you
can find clothes in the store to fit you
yeah and and this is the interesting
part I am living I live in the U.S the
biggest people in the like uh world and
I can I barely find the t-shirts and
stuff on me and I was so afraid of those
thing fact that I'm not I'm gonna be
like just have any clothes on me instead
of something that I like it yeah so it
was one one part
there is many things many factors that
make me to lose my weight or make me
think to change my life towards like
healthy style a healthy healthy
lifestyle so this was one of the things
and I suggest anybody to to go and think
about that to change the life you know
tell me how did you feel before before
you started to really take the matter
serious what were you feeling like what
was your day-to-day like you know what
was your mood like did it affect your
mood what did you have were you
diagnosed with any diabetes or any other
chronic diseases because of the weight
uh I was pretty diabetic they checked me
I had a very high sugar I I had fatty
liver I had like all my organs with the
fat you know it was like it was a down
downward spiral it would just get worse
absolutely it's getting worse and I I
can't move anymore so for example is it
affecting your joints and your bone it
it affects anything and think any
aspects of your life it's affecting
everything yeah you're snoring you can't
sleep you're snoring at the night you
cannot sleep you uh
waking up tired you know you don't want
to have activity at all so energy is low
totally energy low I will to do anything
is low your will is low everything
anything so that's affecting how's your
ibadan how it's affecting your ibada
also absolutely absolutely and that we
know that Muslims should be strong yeah
we have that we know that Hadith
stronger stronger Muslim uh better than
the weaker but both of them Allah loves
both of them so like it's my uh maybe a
wrong interpretation so but we know that
we have to be strong also one more thing
what I was thinking about what if
somebody came outside and touch my wife
do something to my family what if he
gonna mess with me what he gonna fight
or something anything can happen these
days so how I'm gonna protect myself my
family my wife now you're starting to
really think about it I'm thinking about
that even though I was confident in
myself I I thought I am confident now I
understand I was totally like
yeah yeah I used to train but I realized
that I couldn't move I couldn't run like
200 feet so what I'm gonna do is
somebody just gonna yeah beat me up and
this is this is what this was like uh
one of the triggers uh my healthy Health
one of the triggers my family my like a
future child so a lot of things just
kind of came up together okay so now you
make the Dua you take the action behind
the Dua and now you start implementing
certain things what were the what were
some of the combination of things
because sometimes people say man I'm
working out I'm running I'm still not
losing weight
this is the thing
85 to 90 percent of the success is a is
your kitchen it's the kitchen it's the
kitchen so more important than exercise
is what you put in your body absolutely
absolutely that is true there is no
genie in the bottle it's it's easiest
thing like a easiest thing like uh you
don't have to like look for some this
kind of kind of diet this kind of diet
just eat less eat clean eat real food
eat real food yeah avoid fake food
absolutely absolutely nowadays it's
plenty of that food even though it says
healthy but when you read the actual
ingredients it's unfortunately it's so
bad so just go like a real food like
whatever like uh greens vegetables like
meat like uh also meat like a try to
find grass-fed you know anything
anything real like yeah don't don't buy
the junk like sausages or whatever it is
you know there is nothing real Coca-Cola
how do you feel when you go to the
Masjid and you see a table of people who
are in the health profession industry
and they're having Coca-Cola all around
the table
this is I unfortunately
unfortunately this is all around and I
was thinking about one thing I was
chubby at that moment almost 400 pounds
and I was looking at some imams or the
extra way so what's in my what the imams
I'm promoting healthy lifestyle like a
worship to Allah right way right yes and
we have we know that we have a Hadith
uh third part of our stomach for the air
third part for the foot third part for
the water
how how overweighted Imam will talk
about that to the public I put myself in
his position I I wasn't like judging him
but I was thinking about myself how I'm
gonna talk about that how I'm gonna give
dawa for somebody yeah about how you
started thinking about that absolutely
absolutely I was I was putting myself on
the member talking about a life life
like a be healthy because Muslims should
be healthy so you're doing the Mind
thing again like you said it starts from
up here so now you're psyching yourself
up like with your family and this is
another aspect to that absolutely
absolutely so this is another thing
Eddie it sounds crazy probably but I was
thinking okay I am dying 400 pounds how
people gonna Carry Me well I came to
that point how people gonna kill him how
are people that's really something
important to think about so you're that
weight almost 400 pounds and you're
thinking now if I don't lose this how
they gonna carry me
absolutely
brilliant so I was thinking about that I
was thinking about like any aspect in
your life also you're buying car you're
buying car because the car that you're
gonna fit in not car that you're gonna
like yeah not car that you need actually
were you having a hard time fitting in
cars hopefully I I my choice of the car
like before this one it was only based
on my weight yeah I I picked that you
had to actually get a car based on your
weight now absolutely wow absolutely I'm
telling you every aspect of the life how
many people actually they can relate
they're actually going through something
similar right now inshallah this could
be a benefit to help them go ahead and
Implement some of these things that you
did to make a change absolutely
absolutely this is this is something
that we have to to think about deeper
because back home
you know about getting me to the janaza
back home we don't have like we don't
use like escorts like we do in the
America with kidding but it's like mile
something off work like within the
village the cemetery is not far away so
we get it all the time on the hands so
yeah sure sometimes somebody heavier
somebody lighter and I was getting
somebody heavy yeah but I was twice
heavier than the who I'm kidding yes and
I'm like subhanallah how much Zoom I'm
giving to the people who are gonna carry
me to the to the My Grave yeah so this
was one thing another thing like any any
anything like every day's lifestyle you
know walking to them as just coming back
like I'm making ribada even though when
you go to that and like uh subhanallah
this is one another thing that I was
thinking about before Ramadan when I
realized like three four months left and
I start remembering if I go to the
sajdah and Imam gonna make long Dua in
the sajdah I can breathe you I can stay
there because whole thing like uh
pushing me down you're having a hard
time breathing in absolutely that's
because the excess weight you're
carrying it's really affecting you that
much absolutely absolutely anything
anything I'm telling you there is no
even single higher in your extra weight
this is why you have to why you have to
I mean I was thinking about well lie and
when I gained my weight I'm like I have
to do something and when I when I go to
sajdah I couldn't breathe I my forehead
my forehead has a lot of pressure you
know my hands getting tired you know and
that's like many things yeah many things
so number one thing is
food
the food that you put in your body
that's the number one thing and then
what the added bonus obviously now the
exercise because that plays I mean you
actually went and ran a you participated
in a triathlon yeah I did Triathlon uh
brother Osama from the abor Masjid he he
offered me let's let's do Triathlon and
I was on the point that I lost some
weight but I now I have to implement the
more exercise yeah so uh just in sake of
save my joints and stuff without running
on the extra weight and stuff and now I
have to start some exercises and the
right that day or day before I bought
the bike to start biking instead of
running because I wanna I don't wanna
put a lot of pressure on my joints so he
offered me let's do we're gonna do all
of us I'm like I didn't even think a
second I said what is it he said like
we're gonna like uh swim half a mile
we're gonna run three miles and we're
gonna do bike 15 miles
even though I never done it before I
said I'm gonna do it and then walai I
came home I think right like after one
hour I sign up and I sent the proof to
Osama I said Osama I am in so I'm I'm
not gonna have a way to back you know
get back so I mean I'm gonna start
training and then I call to my coach I
said okay Coach I'm gonna have a
triathlon let's get ready so this was
mashallah very good point uh very good
motivation for me to start running
swimming and the biking for sure and we
know that swimming is Sunnah so uh
I started swimming I start from two laps
three laps then I I started adding on
adding on alhamdulillah ended up with
like almost 40 laps in there on the pool
so also running uh never like running I
hate it even though even with the goats
yeah the goats is different level now
so yeah running alhamdul I went I
started running I started walking I
started jogging I start brother I want
to give advice for everyone
don't think you have to run three miles
straight first day start with the half
mile walking then at half mile jogging
one week half mile another week one mile
another week one and a half mile and
then always think about that you can do
it because your mind will pull you pull
you back but your body can do much more
so always work with your mind and then
say yourself I will do it I can do it
this is what happened to me
alhamdulillah I went from the half a
mile to one mile just just by saying
myself
everybody doing around me I saw women
running around I saw grandmas running
around so how how I am 28 29 yeah 29
year old 28 year old guy uh I'm uh
pretending to be like a tough guy from
the high mountains like uh judoka this
and that you know now I have to push
myself I push myself alhamdul to one
mile one and a half mile ended up
alhamdulillah was like almost six miles
in total you know so it this is
something that you have to work with
so how do you feel now versus how you
were feeling then
this is like a white and black
now I'm white
I came back from the darkness of your
health you know of your movements of
your like spending your time with your
family spending your time
exercising find like a alhamdula this
Triathlon
give me opportunity to meet a lot of
good Brothers you know we met there we
we did something together it's now I
have like 50 plus friends Brothers yeah
that I know I have a phones we talk to
each other this is something something
incredible and
even if if before I was calling to my
friends like where are we gonna go to
eat yeah now I'm calling like where are
we gonna go Jack where are we gonna go
swim where are we gonna go bike so so
the diabetes is gone how come the
pre-diabetes everything is gone I do my
blood check every three three months I
check everything I need so I'm adding
whatever I have you're not on any uh
pharmaceutical description no no no
alhamdulillah I have everything is good
so now I'm just taking like a regular
over the counter every vitamin C vitamin
B like just regular stuff yeah so you
don't really need anything like extra
you know but uh the key is Eddie you you
don't have to you don't have to make it
complicated you have you don't have to
think it's something complicated 70 of
success just stop eating drunk just
start eating real food this is the
message that we anytime we talk about
nutrition lifestyle number one thing
usually is like you just said you
testify to is the food absolutely eat
real food avoid fake food even before
that you started with the Dua so number
one your connection with your creators
you may Dua to God Almighty Allah and
then you took the action and you realize
okay food is the number one thing I got
to stop eating all this garbage fake
food because you can be running jumping
jogging working out but you're eating
snicker bars drinking Coca-Cola you're
just defeating the purpose right so okay
so we got that Dua
action you started to clean up your
cupboards
implementing real food you name some of
those foods that you were eating just
vegetables Meats great just real food
just real food real food yeah real food
not there is nothing special yeah that's
the food that the Creator Allah gave us
don't eat that sausages don't eat like
that bad things you know like a I don't
know like a Cokes like uh Coca-Cola 7Up
Snicker boxes drink water this is the
best thing to drink this is the best
thing to drink just a drink of water and
be hydrated for sure you know and
everything coming back somebody talking
about this diet somebody talking about
carnivore that keto do anything just do
you know and and you don't eat like too
much even though you're following like a
carnivore diet like this diet that diet
just a smaller your portions follow
everything anything I have read about
that everything I listen about like a
healthy food and a healthy lifestyle
it's coming back to Sunnah it's coming
back to the Sunnah about eating less
yeah eating less subhanallah you can
follow any diet yeah just eat less
that's it subhanallah so there's a lot
to begin here inshallah this could be a
inspiration motivation seeing you Eldar
who was almost 400 pounds and making
such the prostrating can't breathe
worrying about how they're going to
carry you to your cat to your right your
janaza and your grave thinking about
those kind of things and the other
things you were you were doing to psych
yourself up here with the mind and then
implementing you start eating real food
you start exercising you're here with us
now because you guys can see the
pictures you can see the difference yeah
it's amazing so don't give up it's never
too late uh there's probably people
right now who are overweight maybe not
even just half the amount that you were
but you were at such a level people
become so sensitive sometimes and you
can't say anything to them did you go
through that also there were people
telling you we're not talking about
people like bullying people or you know
uh name con but I'm talking about
sometimes you got to tell someone
straight you know what I mean so what's
your opinion what we talked about that a
little bit yeah this is the problem this
is the big problem when you're trying to
say to obviously let's talk about myself
so did you ever make an excuse say this
is just big bones
this is the thing that I want to mention
about yeah uh I wanna everyone to tell
truth to your to that person next to you
if you see him he's overweighted don't
try to tell him you are teddy bear you
are Little Panda you are just fluffy
this and that it's you it's disease he's
he's in the problem huge problem if you
really consider him as a brother friend
or something tell him truth tell him
like that don't hurt him but be gentle
but tell him brother you have a weight
and it can affect on your body on your
on your heart on your like overall like
a Lifeline you know so just think about
it what happened to me people always say
oh you just big you're just drunk now
I'm saying why did you lie to me I
wasn't just a big I was fat you know I
was overweighted like 200 like uh 400
pounds like it's almost 200 pounds over
so you said why didn't you tell me you
guys are caressing me you know
sanitizing it you know
now I'm telling to all my friends why
didn't you tell me that I am fat
actually not fluffy not Panda or not
teddy bear you know this is something
you're not gonna you're not gonna tell
to person who trying to uh jump from the
from the high building or whatever
you're not gonna play with him you're
gonna say you're gonna die man don't
jump into it yes the same thing what's
the difference I'm gonna die not today
maybe but tomorrow yeah you have an
overweight you have a problem you were
heading that direction I would have
gotten worse and worse and worse
absolutely I will tell you more I have
uh Apple watch for like uh good like six
seven years already and I check my chart
I start checking it I'm like let me see
my heart rate what was it and what is
now
this is this is something incredible and
I want everybody to listen that that
moment
when I was overweighted I had like a
rested heart rate 87 beats per minute
when I lost my weight when I came like
down for 60 pounds my heart rate was 53
so it means your heart worked more
efficient it doesn't need to boom boom
boom boom you know because your veins
your everything it's stuck it's clocked
you know and it doesn't have to work
hard
it came back to 53. now it were more
efficient like boom boom you know your
bloodstream then when I started working
out what happened it went down even less
45 so my heart that happened that
telling me thank you thank you that you
lost your weight thank you for being
healthy and the 87 and 45 it's a huge
difference it's a huge difference so
yeah this is this is really interesting
part for me uh when I checked it yeah
this could be a motivation for you and
others out there who are sitting on the
couch making a Duo you're not taking the
action you can go and benefit from the
story take some action and inshallah
make a change for the better thank you
my brother thank you brother everybody I
hope this is gonna be beneficial for you
guys never stop alhamdulillah I'm pretty
sure 99 of those who watching this video
wasn't even close to 400 pounds but you
need to do a little bit just make Dua
just start from something and Allah will
help you inshallah if one person accept
Islam because of you because of your
effort it's worth more than holding it
this is your brother Abdul hawalda from
Dallas Texas I'm here in support of the
dean center it's a beautiful
organization Masha Allah in the U.S and
they have purchased a piece of land and
several building on it and we are
counting our brother and sister
throughout the US throughout the world
to be part of this magnificent project
it doesn't matter how much you give it
doesn't matter how much you donate what
matter we all participate inshallah may
Allah bless you thank you so much
cannot leave without giving you a gift
if you are not yet Muslim and you tune
in to see what these Muslims are talking
about and you like a free copy of the
Quran go and visit thedineshow.com we'll
take care of the postage and everything
and get it delivered to you and if you
still have some questions
about Islam call us at
1-800-662-4752 we'll see you next time
until then peace be with you and if you
like this episode of the dean show like
this video
share this video far and wide and
support us on our patreon page so we can
continue this work thank you for tuning
in peace be with you assalamualaikum